[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine un voyage en terrain connu pour
sa nouvelle journée fait de l'histoire
les archives départementales s'intéresse
au lieu de vie de nombreuses animations
sont programmées
l'aventuré la nature les deux thèmes du
salon du livre d'elancourt pour sa
troisième édition le salon organisé par
les amis du passé d'elancourt accueille
70 participants et l'agenda complet de
vous sortir au programme du cinéma de la
solidarité et une exposition
ce samedi les archives départementales
fait l'histoire après le centenaire de
la grande guerre la journée participent
et il s'intéresse au lieu de vie aux
questions liées au territoire une
journée à laquelle s'est associé le
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
un rapide coup d'oeil sur la
programmation les images on cinématique
de 2006 je vous ai sorti
un exemplaire de ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le cadastre napoléonien donc
le premier cadastre qui étaient
élaborées dans le premier tiers du 19e
siècle
un atlas qui détaille chaque commune du
département un document d'habitude
consultable sur internet
mais pour leur nouvelle édition de
faites de l'histoire les archives
départementales le feront découvrir au
public
nous proposerons notamment à l'occasion
de cette journée du 23 un atelier qui
permettra aux personnes de se
familiariser à la recherche pour faire
l'historique de sa maison
quelles sont les ressources que l'on
peut consulter quelles sont les
ressources disponibles chez nous est ce
qu'elles sont consultables en ligne
faire l'histoire de sa maison à travers
les âges cette année les archives
s'intéresse à l'urbanisme et au lieu de
vie fait on voit au niveau de la rue où
est installée la cité des dents de scie
que les habitants sont quasiment pour la
plupart les employés de chemin de fer
les trois uniques qui seront proposées
ce jour là
eh bien ce sera la visite du quartier la
sourderie le quartier des dents de scie
et une thématique sur la hainaut a 50
ans jeu de piste contes pour les enfants
ou encore oeuvre collaborative les
archives départementales se sont
associés pour cette journée au musée de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
dans un peu plus d'un mois le père noël
passera déposer les cadeaux au pied du
sapin vous est peut-être en train de
créer votre liste alors la foire aux
jouets du centre alfred de vigny est un
bon moyen pour la compléter
rendez vous dimanche 24 novembre de 9h à
voisins le bretonneux en sport c'est un
stage qui vous attend le karaté-club
plaisir roi propose aux licenciés de la
fédération un stage technique
le rendez-vous est dirigée par un expert
fédéral national auprès de la fédération
m naoki aux mines 9e dan vous dispensera
ses conseils à partir de 9 heures on
découvre maintenant nos rendez vous
culturel le téléthon le téléthon c'est
les sites les 6 et 7 décembre prochain
mais certaines associations proposent
déjà des animations et c'est le cada pas
de géant à guyancourt l'association
propose un spectacle d'improvisation
ce samedi 23 novembre l'équipe adulte
les improbables vous propose trois
heures de spectacle prix d'entrée 3
euros minimum les bénéfices seront
entièrement reversés à l'afm
c'est une soirée au cours duquel on se
déroulera à cabaret d'improvisation un
format alternatif au match qu'on connaît
donc ya pas deux équipes mais un
ensemble de joueurs dont tient
provisions sur des thèmes n'ont pas
donné par un arbitre mais par un maître
de cérémonie
en collaboration avec le public pourra
même donné de sa personne sur scène pour
jouer avec nous et on improvisera autour
d'un thème qui était le thème des
couleurs donc qui pourra passer par les
vêtements par les thèmes les musiques ou
autre mais ça mais moi je ne le sais pas
c'est un rendez vous qui a pris date le
salon du livre des longs cours a lieu ce
week-end bernard delattre bonjour jouent
alors vous êtes l'un des organisateurs
de cet événement et cette année
il y aura 70 participants auteurs 72 62
c'est la troisième organisation des amis
du passé des concours présidé par jean
photo une association qui faisait les
vendanges qui fait des livres sur l
encours et l'âne depuis trois ans on a
eu l'idée d'un salon ça marche bien on
2000 visiteurs les deux premières
éditions avec jean françois kahn
notamment la dernière et là on espère
faire encore mieux avec un beau thème
aventure découverte nature et comme
président d'honneur patrice franceschi
cas vraiment prix goncourt de la
nouvelle 2015 aventure et explorateur il
a fait le tour du monde en ulm avec son
bateau trois mâts la boudeuse sur les
traces de bougainville voilà il s'est
battu pour défendre les kurdes contre
des cetc quoi c'est un type hors norme
et un grand philosophe aussi vraiment un
humaniste c'est vraiment intérêt
quelqu'un d'intéressant à rencontrer
quoi vous avez donné le thème de cette
année c'est l'aventuré la découverte la
nature vous souhaitez faire voyager le
public aussi en découvrant des auteurs
sur ces thèmes voilà tout à fait ouais
vous même c'est ça le voyage la
découverte
on n'a pas à andré brugiroux qui a fait
400 mille kilomètres autour du monde en
stop en auto-stop bateau stock tout ça
pas 400 mille kilomètres en une seule
fois je pense sur dix ans et il va faire
une conférence il ya brigitte blot qui a
voyagé avec son âne qui a fait le tour
de france avec son âne pour ça va être
passionnant on assez michel parneix le
kin spécialistes d'australie
spécialiste de l'art aborigène qui va
nous parler l'art médecin comment l'art
aborigène les fameux tableau servent
aussi comme médecine mais nous avons
aussi la nature avec dominique julien
labruyère qui est un des fondateurs du
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse un peu plus dans le local à
qui va nous expliquer quel est l'intérêt
justement des parcs naturels pour
défendre la nature d'un territoire
c'était des lances à sont ceux qui vont
animer des conférences mais aussi des
grands noms qui seront en tant
qu'exposant on va dire je suis
auteur il ya pris messieurs michel
moutot grand journaliste prix albert
londres
valère staraselski qu'est d'origine
polonaise prix de la licra
georges grard qui est un auteur éditeur
qui a eu le prix de la fédération du
handicap pour sa petite bande dessinée
la bande am c'est une bande de copains
qui sont handicapés il on est ici vivent
comme les autres c'est très très très
bien être très positif on a line dresse
aussi les des éditions glyphe kyi qui a
été la fameuse actrice de la tendresse
bordel avec le regretté bernard
giraudeau ensuite elle a été choisie
comment vous les trouvez sur les salons
étant moi-même un potter donc je vais
sur les salons je rencontre des gens et
puis secret vite des liens et puis au
fil on rencontre des gens et puis c'est
aussi quelqu'un si tu essaies car à
l'embauché tinos qui travaille à
l'ambassade de chypre mais je pense
qu'il n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
avec les turcs qui ont envahi quand même
faut le dire une partie de chypre où il
faut saluer comme le temps passe très
vite je voudrais qu'on fasse un petit
mot sur patrice sanchez qui vous avait
parlé parce que le salon se délocalise
un peu le samedi à 2 oui ces projections
pardon au ciné c'est parce qu'on peut
faire un petit moral sud soit celle ci
c'est la première fois qu'on a partagé
avec le ciné c'est donc effectivement le
samedi 23 mai à 18h15 de films de
patrice franceschi seront projetés à
deux films d'environ 50 minutes une
heure le premier c'est là la boudeuse au
vent la guyane après sa traversée de
l'atlantique nord ils ont remonté
l'amazone avec des scientifiques pour
étudier la faune flore est le deuxième
film c'est 3 ça et puis paris ces trois
hommes d'une tribu primitive que
patrice avait rencontré il les a fait
venir à paris c'était des gens habitués
à vivre en prime et là il découvre paris
et c'est à une vraie rencontre humaniste
en trop mais entre humains et c'est
vraiment passionnant quoi toujours une
recherche humaniste de francesca quoi
merci bernard delattre a le temps s'il
est un peu mais le salon du livre
d'elancourt débute à 10h le dimanche 24
novembre mais comme on disait il ya des
séances des projections au ciné cette
alors pour ne rien rater de ce rendez
vous la commande et le dimanche le ciné
le samedi on continue et du livre parce
qu'il est à l'honneur ce week-end aussi
à versailles puisque la ville accueille
la 12e édition du salon histoire de lire
un salon qui se tient sur deux jours les
23 et 24 novembre alors seront présents
des auteurs de romans d'essayer de bande
dessinée bien sûr un fil rouge
l'histoire quelques mots du commissaire
du salon il était l'invité de wilfrid
richy dans le 7-8 journal notre objectif
effectivement ces deux de transmettre au
plus grand nombre
donc effectivement ddd des journalistes
des comédiens des hommes politiques sont
aussi là parce que on est tous concernés
par par l'histoire et l'écriture de
l'histoire qu'on a aussi un chapiteau
une tente avec 2 35 auteurs pour la
jeunesse dès le premier âge et puis vous
parler peut-être d'aidé youtuber on
passe maintenant à notre moment cinéma
avec un film très attendu par les jeunes
et les moins jeunes six ans après la
sortie de la reine des neiges
le deuxième volet est projeté dans les
salles depuis hier mercredi 20 novembre
les rênes des neiges de la rédaction
aurélie rose et manon varaldo ont
recueilli vos réactions
[Musique]
j'entends une voix bizarre comment ça
une très belle suite avec un scénario
qui est assez inattendu souvent on se
dit que les deuxièmes parties sont un
peu décevantes et là pour le coup
vraiment une très belle réalisation et
beaucoup d'émotion sur le coup j'ai pas
trop accroché parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de musique et je me suis dit
que ce serait que qu'il y aurait que des
paroles en musique puis après je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'action et tout ça et ça m'a beaucoup
plu
elles avaient des talons blanc des
talons bleus et la changer de couette
elle a des faits sa tresse elle allie la
ligne que tu vas aller après la lâcher
ses cheveux j'ai bien aimé
alors pourquoi tu l'as bien aimé est ce
que ça faisait un petit peu peur mais
j'aime bien être qui font peur
l'histoire les musiques ça c'est ma
petite fille qui va faire la réflexion
qui a vu la première
la première version elle m'a signalé
quand même que les musiques étaient trop
et d'antiques dans la reine des neiges 2
voilà y'a pas à libérer des livres et
c'est pas la même chose
je crois en toi y va
on apportera
[Musique]
une silhouette reconnaissable au premier
coup d'oeil mais un amour pour la
musique peut être moins connus l'homme
orchestre charlie chaplin est décrypté
dans une exposition à la philharmonie de
paris
les sujets et de nos confrères de via
grand paris légende du cinéma muet clown
le plus célèbre du monde sous ses traits
de charlot charlie chaplin s'expose en
musique à la philharmonie de paris
l'homme orchestre revient sur l'étroite
relation entre la musique et les films
de l'acteur
l'action est musique second chaplin très
impliqué dans les choix musicaux de ces
longs métrages et ce n'est pas un hasard
lui qui se prédestinait d'abord à
devenir musicien chaplin
venez donc d'une famille de chanteur et
d'acteur de music hall est donc très tôt
il a été sur les planches il a appris à
chanter et il s'est mis au violon mois à
partir de la fin de son adolescence tout
seul et il est donc il a essayé de
devenir violoniste il avait envie de
faire une carrière et il avait le
sentiment qu'il n'était pas à la hauteur
et donc qui s'est tourné vers le cinéma
une stick comme c'est le maître du
cinéma muet a priori on n'imagine pas ce
lien extrêmement étroit mais en fait
tout le parcours raconte que la musique
fait complètement partie de l'imaginaire
de charlie chaplin l'exposition vous
invitent à déambuler dans un décor de
film où se mêlent extraits vidéo
affiches photos et instruments le rendez
vous a également été adapté pour
sensibiliser les plus jeunes à l'oeuvre
de chaplin avec la possibilité de
rentrer dans la peau du personnage et
offre aux enfants la possibilité de
mettre un le chapeau de charlot sur la
tête une petite veste et ensuite au sein
du parcours ils ont effectivement des
gags à la chaplin
c'est à dire des portes que l'on
traverse à leur hauteur des portes qui
ne s'ouvrent pas et puis ils peuvent
jouer avec une machine à bruitages ils
peuvent reconstruire un charlot cubiste
on a un hologramme donc voila tout au
long du parcours
il ya ce discours qui s'adresse aussi
bien aux adultes qu'aux enfants
venez rythmer votre journée avec charlie
chaplin à la philharmonie de paris
jusqu'au 26 janvier prochain c'est la
fin de ce statut doit dire merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
oh